For most of this course,
we have focused on economic or peculiarity
damages such as compensating an
aggrieved party for the
value of lost property,
future earnings or cost of repair.
But in this lesson we will
learn about contract loss,
treatment of other types of damages,
especially emotional damages and
punitive damages will examine two cases.
Bo Hawk versus department of Agriculture
and rite aid corporation versus lake
shore investors.
Let's start with the bow hot case
which is about non pecuniary emotional
damages.
The plaintiff appellant in this case
Janice Bow Hawk is a research geneticist
who was removed from her position
with the Department of Agriculture.
Plaintiff claimed that her removal
was a violation of the whistle blower
protection act and sued for $14,000 for
Picayune Arie losses and $150,000 for
non peculiarity damages as a
result of her wrongful termination.
Just so we're on the same page,
pecuniary means of relating
to or consisting of money
and be Cuny Arie damages
or losses that can be easily
quantified in monetary terms.
Non pecuniary damages are not
readily quantified in monetary terms.
For example,
a plaintiff medical bills are pecuniary
losses whereas her emotional distress
and pain and suffering
are non pecuniary losses.
After her removal,
plaintiff filed a motion for damages with
the Merit System Protection Board and
Administrative Law Judge for the board
granted her motion for pecuniary damages
but rejected her claim
for non pecuniary damages.
Holding that non pecuniary damages do
not constitute consequential damages.
Plaintiff then petition for review
of the decision by the full board.
The petition was rejected.
The plaintiff then appealed to the instant
court and the instinct court affirmed
the board's decisions.
Okay,
so here's a quiz.
Why was the focus of the court's inquiry
on consequential damages as opposed to
compensatory damages?
Okay,
well,
Congress apparently intended to protect
whistleblowing federal employees from
discharge by incorporating the common
law meaning of consequential damages into
the act.
As you may have noticed,
the bowl hot court suggested that it's
decision might have been different if
compensatory rather than consequential
damages was intended by the whistle
blower protection act.
Okay.
The main issue in this case is whether
non pecuniary damages are considered
consequential damages.
You should recall from our lesson on
Hadley vs Baxendale that a breaching party
is liable for consequential damages.
That is for losses that the contracting
parties should have foreseen.
In other words,
the issue in Bo Hawk is
whether [inaudible] damages
are foreseeable according to
the rule of Hadley feedbacks and Dale
consequential damages are easiest for
courts to see when the
breaching party as a seller.
Here are the breaching party is a buyer,
the employer who is buying
the plaintiff's employment.
In this case the court held that no non
pecuniary damages are not sufficiently
foreseeable to be awarded.
Non Peculiarity damages are generally
unforeseeable when the contract is signed.
As a result, consequential damages
are limited to pecuniary damages.
The second restatement states that mental
anguish is recoverable in a contract
breach when the quote breach is of
such a kind that serious emotional
disturbance was a particularly
likely result unquote,
or if the breach also caused bodily harm.
The prevailing view is that emotional
distress damages are not available for
breach of an employment contract.
For instance,
one case emphasize that
employment contracts do not
have elements of personality
and that parties did not agree to protect
those types of losses even though an
ordinary employment contract
and might be excluded.
The fact that the discharge employee is
a whistle blower and is discharged for
that fact brings the likelihood of
emotional disturbance into play.
The focus for the second restatement
is the likelihood of d of emotional
disturbance at the time of breach,
not the time of contracting,
but one can ask whether this presumption
against awarding employees damages for
emotional distress is
merely a default rule.
If the initial contract had called for
such damages or otherwise indicated that
serious emotional distress is likely,
would courts be willing to enforce that
kind of promise? Well, it's not clear.
There's a lot of judicial reluctance
to expand damages in this way.
Then again,
if the parties contract says so
explicitly that they wanted it,
it's a,
it might happen.
Claims for mental anguish or emotional
distress damages are on the borderline
between contract and tort.
The emotional disturbance results
from a breach of contract,
say a wrongful termination,
but the injury is to what might be
called a tort rather than a contractual
interest. Uh, in addition to
losing the value of the bargain,
the plaintiff is worse off
physically than before the contract.
In one Hawaii case,
the court rejected awarding damages for
tortious breach of contract because such
a would blur the theories of recovery
relevant to tort and contract.
They held that emotional distress damages
will only be awarded where parties
specifically provide for
them in the contract or were
or were clearly within the
contemplation of the parties.
So at least in Hawaii,
the presumption against a war II awarding
emotional distress damages is just a
default. It can be contracted round
in the initial contract itself.
Okay,
let's switch gears and take a
look at another type of damages.
Punitive damages in rite aid
corporation versus lake shore investors.
The plaintiff Appellee Lake shore sued
the defendant rite aid for falsely
claiming that a valid lease agreement
existed between the two. Uh,
the two of them when it did not.
Lake shore also sued rite aid for
interference with another contract because
rite aid refused to provide a release
allowing a third party purchaser to
withdraw from its deal with lake shore
if the rite aid claim over the property
became an issue.
Okay.
The trial court did not
distinguish between these
two separate causes of action
and it also refuse to
award punitive damages.
Plaintiff appealed and the
Court of special appeals
reversed and held that lake
shore should have been able to prove
damages that would quote reasonably flow
from a tortious contractual interference.
Defendant appealed and the instinct
court affirmed and remanded.
The main issue we are interested in is
whether punitive damages can be recovered
for an action of tortious
interference with the contract.
The court answered yes
allowing punitive damages.
The holding is consistent
with the interpretation of
the second restatement of
torts which states that a person injured
by tortious interference with the
contract can recover punitive damages
where appropriate in order for punitive
damages to be appropriate to
conditions must be met. First,
there must be an award of
compensatory damages and second,
there must be actual malice.
The court in this case remanded to
the trial court to apply this test.
The tort of intentional interference
with the contract is explained in section
seven 66 of the second
restatement of torts.
It applies to cases where
a party intentionally and
improperly interferes with
the performance of a contract or induces
a third person not to perform the
contract.
In addition to intentional
interference with existing contracts,
courts have also found tort
liability for third parties,
intentional interference with prospective
and even negligent interference.
Well,
I've heard that Columbia law school once
threatened to sue Yale Law School for
poaching on law applicants who
had put in deposits with Columbia.
Columbia claimed that making a competitive
offer was intentionally interfering
with Columbia's contracts
as rite aid versus lake shore
demonstrates most states follow the second
restatement of torts and permit
an intentional interference
plaintiff to recover
inappropriate cases for emotional
distress, for harm to reputation,
and even punitive damages measures that
would not be available in an action for
contractual breach.
Some scholars have analogize the
toward of intentional interference with
contracts to rules that protect property
owners against theft such as the tort
of conversion.
Having a tort against
interference increases promises,
chances of realizing the benefits of
having secured the promise of performance.
But courts have been fickle about when
exactly and interferences improper.
Okay.
Does awarding punitive damages for the
tort of intentional interference with a
contract undermine the
goals of contract law?
The law of intentional interference
is inconsistent with contract laws.
Strong preference for
only compensatory damages.
Some have argued that allowing the tort
of intentional interference runs counter
to the theory of efficient breach
contract rules are designed to facilitate
breach where efficiency
gains were will result,
but the interference liability rule
might reduce the number of such breaches.
It's also possible for a breach of an
implied covenant of good faith and fair
dealing to constitute a tort for
which punitive damages may be awarded.
California courts have long held
that in insurance contracts,
the insurer's refusal to settle with,
uh,
within the terms of an insurance policy
or to pay an undisputed claim of a,
uh,
to an insured may be bad.
Faith may be a bad faith
toward for which the, uh,
insured can recover damages for mental
anguish and even punitive damages.
In the 1984 Siemens case,
the California Supreme Court held that
tort liability for a bad faith breach can
be opposed beyond insurance contracts.
Other kinds of promises can be tagged
with punitive damages for a bad faith
breach,
but only if certain
qualifications are met in Siemens.
The court emphasized tort remedies may
be appropriate when a party seeks to
shield itself from liability by
denying that the contract exists.
The court explained that tort remedies
are appropriate where a contracting party
seeks to avoid all liability on
a meritorious contract claim.
By adopting a stonewall position,
we'll have see you in court with no
belief in the that it has a valid defense.
The court went on to explain these cases.
Uh,
go beyond the mere breach of contract
making tort liability permissible.
The Siemens rule is controversial.
Judge Alex Kosinski criticize the rule
for being in the cloud cuckoo land of
modern tort theory and
subordinary voluntary contractual
arrangements to judge's
own sense of public policy. On
the other hand, Gregory class,
my coauthor has defended the seam and
rule arguing that punitive damages are
needed because compensatory damages
do not sufficiently deter the source,
the source of stonewalling
observed in Siemens.
In summary,
there are many hurdles for recovering
non pecuniary and or punitive damages for
a contractual breach.
As the Bow Hawk case
demonstrates non peculiarity,
emotional damages are
generally not recoverable.
The restatement states that mental anguish
is only recoverable when the breach
is likely to result in serious
emotional disturbance. Even then,
ordinary employment contracts normally
do not award this kind of damages.
Rite aid stands for the principle that
punitive damages may be possible for an
intentional interference with the
contractual relationship. However,
for punitive damages to apply,
there must be an award of compensatory
damages and there must be actual malice
present.